Let's start right now. Welcome to another Zoom call. Just a reminder for anybody listening.
That is new. Please use the members. Only site to see all announcements. You'll see what's new.
Anything that's new. Nothing's been new. Really updated this week except I'm adding blogs.
So I'm adding links to new blogs when they're appropriate or you know, semi-appropriate for you guys.
So you'll see that on the home page links to different blogs. There's a immune system. There's a gut health blog with some
protocols for different things too. So make sure you look at that. You can always access the blogs by looking at this little
magnifying glass thing with jiggy and click any subject you want. Let's jump to the questions.
What are your thoughts about using soy in the diet for somebody who has had an estrogen-driven cancer?
Well, I'm not a fan of using soy in the diet even if you don't have an estrogen-driven cancer.
We are exposed to way too many zero-estrogens as it is. And soy,
iso-levelins have different our estrogen stimulators and estrogen mimics.
So I'm not a fan of that at all. Even if it's organic, 95% of the soy grown in the United States and
Canada is GMO, soy, which is horrible for you. Even if you have the ability to get organic done across
contaminated soy, it still has too many estrogen stimulators in it. It's just not a good food.
It's just not anymore. It's just unfortunately because of our exposure to other zero-estrogens,
it's, you know, we cannot handle purposely, purposefully, consuming them.
So nobody should really be eating soy or very little of it, at least.
So you identified my husband as significant micotoxins. So what are micotoxins?
Micotoxins are toxins from mold. So does the current programs you have him to run
each evening include addressing these micotoxins or should his weekly program be updated
or run addition programs to deal with the micotoxins? You're in, say, we appreciate it.
So two things can take place if you're dealing with micotoxins. You can
so understand a micotoxin is not a living organism of mold anymore. It's a toxin
that a mold produced. So all these different types of mold can produce toxins.
So you could have a sensitivity to the organism, the mold itself. That's typically an immune reaction
to the mold. So that's what's called an IgE reaction. So you go into a moldy building and you start
coffee, you go, oh my gosh, I just can't handle this moldy building. I gotta get out of here.
That's a sensitivity to the mold organism. So that's what you could run the right for
to help kill any mold organisms. But a micotoxin is a toxin that the mold produced. So it's not
a living organism. So there's really not rife programs to do, because remember the rife works best
on killing things. So you could run mold programs on the rife. But that's really for when you have
you know a current exposure to mold. It will help kill mold in the house. It will help kill
mold organisms in your body. But it won't kill micotoxins because micotoxins aren't living.
So you have to detoxify micotoxins. You have to keylate micotoxins. You have to use different
nutrients that will grab onto micotoxins and pull them out of your body. So a micotoxin is not a
sensitivity. Micotoxins are poisonous to everybody. So that has nothing to do with your genetics.
Micotoxins are toxins. They're poisons. They're not organic, not living,
they're not organisms. They're poisons. They're chemical poisons that a mold will produce.
So you're not really running the rife to kill micotoxins, because micotoxins aren't living.
I'm going to throw it at that point. You have to keylate those out. You have to grab onto those.
You have to use that diet. You have to use different detox supporting all your detox pathways to get rid
of micotoxins. So there's not really a change in programming. The only thing that I would say that
you could benefit you with the rife with micotoxins is running liver programs to help with detox,
but there's that that is already in each of your night program. I put those in there. Or
running the ion foot bat, the ion pro wave. So ion pro wave programs will help pull things out of your
body. I mean, they're mainly intended to get the higher frequencies in you, but they're certainly
like the clear line detox ion pro wave program will help detox out your body. Other ways to get rid
of micotoxins are with homeopaths with different keylators. Like I said, supporting all your
seven phases of detoxification using the sona, doing coffee animals. Any way you think about
getting rid of like a heavy metal or getting rid of glyphosate or getting rid of poisons in your
body or different toxins is how you get rid of micotoxins. So micotoxins, when you do a micotox test
by mosaic labs, you do that. It's measuring the toxins from past exposure or could be current exposure,
but it's typically past exposure. But you do have to look at current exposure. That's why it's good
to get your house tested. Do we have live in a moldy environment? And many times people will go
yeah, I remember I worked in a really moldy environment several years ago. Well, that could be what was
the exposure. If a patient has M-steed bar virus and heavy metals in the past and currently has cancer,
should the test for M-steed bar and heavy metals be run? Hub maybe. So M-steed bar virus
understand the tests for M-steed bar viruses. So if you're going to run an M-steed bar virus test,
you have to run a test that tests for let me type this in here so you guys can understand this.
You have to test for IgG antibodies and for IgM antibodies. So IgG antibodies test for past exposure.
So if you look at a past M-steed bar virus tested and showed high IgG antibodies, that just means
you had exposure to M-steed bar in the past. You could have had it as a child and you have no current
M-steed bar virus, but you still have M-steed bar virus. That's a good thing. You want antibodies
for different viruses and bacteria, but that says that you were exposed to it in the past. You
shouldn't be treating it if you have elevated IgG antibodies. If you have IgM antibodies, that means
you have a current infection of M-steed bar or anything. So if you're testing anything and you're
testing an antibody test for something, IgG antibodies tell you that you had exposure to it in the past.
It doesn't tell you how bad that exposure was. It doesn't tell you that you were really sick of it
from it in the past. You could have just been exposed to it. Never got sick and developed antibodies.
That does not mean you're sick now and it does not mean that you need to treat it if you have
IgG antibodies. If you have IgM antibodies, well then you should treat for that. Then you should
run the rife. Then you should treat it nutritionally. Then you should depend on what
diseases, if it's a bacterial infection or whatever, maybe use antibiotics. Then you should treat
an active infection. This is past infection. This is an active infection. And as many times different
doctors will run an M-steed bar virus test in particular and see a high elevated IgG antibodies.
Well, you have M-steed bar. We need to treat it. That's just not true. So you want to look at that.
Can you run these tests? I think it's valuable to run any tests. I think all tests are valuable.
We should have a discussion about this. Heavy metals. Everybody's going to have elevated heavy metals.
Some people are going to have more delirious effects of heavy metal exposure. Some people are going
to have increased heavy metal exposure and overwhelm their detox pathways. With everything,
you're just trying to start slow. You've got to go back to the same phase of detox. You've got to
walk through six, five, four, three, two, one before you start pulling stuff out of the tissues too
quickly. So I don't like doing everything all at once. We want to clear out the body, get this
person doing coffee at events, get this person detoxing, get them using the right. Then we can have
a discussion of, okay, what's that deeper step we could go? That's why I created all those courses.
So you could continue to go deeper with your health. Do I have an autoimmune disease? Is that what's
hindered my immune response? Is ability to kill my cancer? Should I deal with that? Do I have heavy
metals? Do I have other things that I need to deal with that taking me to that deeper level?
Now it's going to improve my health. So I'm all for running these tests. The problem with heavy
metal testing, just a side note of this. So heavy metal testing is difficult. So you could do
hair analysis for heavy metal testing. So particularly accurate. It doesn't tell us where we're at right
now. If you had heavy metal, heavy metals in your blood, that would just mean you have an acute
heavy metal toxicity. That should be run in the hospital. If this person gets some like stroke
like symptoms after a possible exposure of arsenic, they'll run a blood heavy metal test and then they
will do IV chelation, hopefully right away to try to chelate that under their blood. If you've had
heavy metal exposure over time, it's not going to stay in the blood and it's going to be in the
tissue. So blood testing for heavy metal really doesn't make any sense from a functional test.
And then there is what's called a push test. And the push test is where you take
excess chelating agents like DMSA and EDTA, which will pull a lot of heavy metals out of the tissues.
And then you do a 24-hour urine test. So it's a push 24-hour urine test
to test for heavy metals. And that's the most accurate way to see how much heavy metals you have
in the tissues. The problem is it's really not good to do health-wise. It's a horrible health test
as far as I don't detect whether you have heavy metals, it'll satisfy your curiosity whether
you do, but it could make you really super sick. So I do not ever recommend doing the provocation test.
And that's what a lot of functional medicine doctors do, but you could really make a person really sick.
The truth is is that we are all exposed to heavy metals and you don't really, in my opinion,
you don't really need to test for them because if you're supporting all the phases of detoxification,
you will be pulling these things out. So there are some better tests to run for other things
other than heavy metals. There's a really good test by Mosaic, but it's on hold right now,
I think the end of, because they're updating the test, the end of July, it's supposed to,
first part of August, it's supposed to be up and running again. And that's going to test for
like 150 different toxins. So that's what I'm excited that that one comes out. Right now, I really
like the glyphosate test that there's several other tests that they have that I like for testing
toxicity. And again, you know, throughout the years of taking care of people from a functional
medicine perspective, it's always really good to look at tests because it gives a person some motivation
to move forward. Most of my cancer patients don't need motivation. And I say, I want you to take this
key later or whatever because it comes up in kinesiology testing. They don't need something on paper,
black and white to be motivated to do it. So I don't typically have to resort to running all these
different labs because they get to be pricey when we could just do treat as if because we know we
have heavy metals, we have to detoxify, we know we have these things. I like to get somewhat of a
picture as much as we possibly can, but and I do recommend hair analysis. Sometimes it's just,
it's sometimes it's good. It's nice for a patient to see. I'll just tell you, it's just not
all that accurate. So that's the only thing I don't like about that. So heavy metal testing is just,
is kind of, you know, you know, hair analysis, not very accurate blood is not going to show it all.
The push test is just not good at all health wise. So we kind of have to resort to kinesiology or
just assumption that we all have heavy metals that we have to deal with. And you certainly can't do
chelation therapy, heavy chelation therapy, if you're a bunch of metal in your mouth, mercury fillings
and such. So you're limited to what you could do with that. But the MC bar and the other different
latent virus test, you want to make sure you run a test that does IGG and IGM, the ones that we have
that I put in room to do both of those. So, but if you are going to see a
local functional medicine doctor concurrently with what you're doing us, you might be good to pass
by me what tests that doctor wants to run just so we're not, you're not running something that's
kind of frivolous. Recently you mentioned that sodium bicarbonate,
animals may stimulate the parasympathetic nervous system also, which is great while I'm doing
through it for these a week as part of my protocol, you still recommend coffee animals too.
So this person is doing animals with sodium bicarbonate instead of coffee. So this person has
colon cancer and the purpose of doing sodium bicarbonate is that they're trying to get the sodium
bicarbonate up to the cancer itself so that the sodium bicarbonate can break up the slide layer
around the cancer because that is acidic and allow his immune system to be able to attack it a little
better. That's the idea of that. The idea of coffee animals has nothing to do with what I just said,
the purpose of a coffee animal is to stimulate the vagal nerve down at the rectal area of your
colon. The vagal nerve is what is responsible for a parasympathetic response. So if you do to
understand what that is, go back and look at this blog and search parasympathetic or sympathetic
and you will see a blog post in a video that comes up to explain what the difference between parasympathetic
and sympathetic is. We want to stimulate the parasympathetics because we live in a world of
sympathetic overdrive. We need that we're in a fight or flight, very high stress
world, especially when we have a serious diagnosis. Our body has this constant inner eggs that you
could only come back from an neurological perspective by stimulating the parasympathetics and call
me the sympathetic in that blog post. I also have written a paper on things to do to call me your
sympathetic. The sympathetic are governed by a part of the brain called the messencephalic center
of the midbrain. That's why it says the messencephalic colbyne exercises and then the parasympathetics are
controlled by the vagal nerve. So those are called vagal stimulating exercises. The vagus is also
cranial nerve 10. So you want to stimulate the parasympathetics and call me the sympathetic.
You could do those concurrently. There's a bunch of different exercises that you could do with,
we'll do that with. One of the best things for that is coffee enemas. Coffee enemas stimulate that
vagal nerve. Sodium macarbonate or chamomile enemas will do that also, maybe to a little lesser degree.
So the question is, should I still do coffee enemas on maybe two, three days a week,
the opposing days that you're not doing the sodium macarbonate enemas? You certainly can. Yep,
absolutely. So there's nothing wrong with doing that as long as the coffee isn't irritating
the tour itself. And we talked a little bit about that, but I don't think it really was in your case.
Okay, that was all the questions we had come in. Is it possible to receive a frequency of
arena cell carcinoma using the bulb as a separate one or two hour program? So you're asking, can
you, can you request from me, for me to give you a like a two hour program of arena cell carcinoma,
even if you don't have, or a different cancer, even if you don't have that cancer. Yes, you can.
So just fill out, we'll go back to the member site. You can fill out the cheek swab request form
because that's cheek swab right for slash right change request form and said that in. So I'll
go to do that and they'll be the same fee for the cheek swab test. And I could set it on a flash drive,
sure. When we last tossed you talked, you recommended clear digest when I read the recent blog about H.
Pylori. In it, you talk about testing with apple cider vinegar. Okay, so let's do this. Let's go to that
blog and I'll pull that up. So the blog post is this one. All right, so I'm going to try to change my
share share or new share. Okay, so everybody can see this new share though. Yes, you can see the
but everybody see the blog post here. Yes, somebody type yes. You can see it. Okay, so here is the
article the blog post. You look back to Pylori information and care. H. Pylori most common bacterial
infection worldwide explains a little bit what H. Pylori does to our body. Kind of important H. Pylori
suppresses the primal cells. The primal cells are the cells of the stomach that are responsible for
making HCl. HCl and I think on this video down here, I didn't actually put this video there as a video
I made about 10 years ago on how H. Pylori has made it. I didn't even listen to the video.
But I think this is my video that explains that in the process of making H. Pylori,
when your body made, when your primal cells make H. Pylori, the byproduct is
hydrogen is sodium macarbonate. And sodium macarbonate that acts as a buffer in the blood. And remember,
I said your blood is constantly buffered and your body is constantly buffered. If your blood doesn't
need the sodium macarbonate, it pushes it to the tissue. So actually, making HCl can help
alkalize your tissue. And deficiency in HCl, a deficiency in your primal cells ability to make HCl
is probably the number one health physiological malhealth in the planet period. And which can
explain one reason why we have more acidic tissue than we probably should. So HCl is super
important in our body. So added HCl to a meal is really important because that takes pressure off
the primal cells and it allows them to start producing HCl again. So when you add HCl to a meal, it
doesn't have a negative feedback loop like adding a hormone to your body would shutting down the
gland that's making the hormone. It doesn't shut down the primal cells of making HCl. It stimulates
them even more because it takes pressure off of them. So it allows them to recover so that they can
start making HCl. And by making HCl, it will also produce sodium macarbonate for the tissues to help
alkalize you should make a video on that. So a decrease HCl causes iron issues so it can cause
anemia issues, can cause osteoporosis, can cause SIBO, which is small intestinal bacterial overgrowth,
decreases our microbiome diversity, which is a huge thing that leads to leaky gut issue. It causes
in systemically, it gets into the bloodstream and causes damaged vascular endothelial cells.
It damages the endothelial cells and the smooth muscle underneath the endothelial cells. It
is one of the top five reasons for cardiovascular disease worldwide. It is the number one cause of
stomach cancer worldwide. It's a molecular mimic to different antibodies in your body. Hpylori is
it can cause an autoimmune attack on the fridal cells, the stomach cells. It can be the cause of type 1
diabetes. It could be like I said, the cause of cardiovascular disease. I see the Hpylori
because major rashes in people's skin cause the list goes on on what Hpylori can cause it. It's
all because of decrease HCl production. This is a loop here. So a decrease HCl sets up Hpylori.
Hpylori increases a loss of the HCl. So it's really important to be taking a digestive enzyme with
HCl. That's why we that's why we a private label the clear digest because it has HCl and a good
slew of digestive enzymes. So you need digestive enzymes to help break down different things, protein
fats and amylase to break down carbohydrates. And those are mainly made in your
pancreas. So you make some of the pridal cells or in the crotted gland as well. But mainly made in
the pancreas. It's created in the droid and HCl is made by the pridal cells and the stomach is created
in the stomach. And when you have a decrease HCl is a major issue. So it's good article to read.
But sometimes people have such a decrease in HCl that when they take a clear digest with HCl and it
causes burning a stomach ache and it can't even take it. Well then you know that's first and
as very similar HCl deficiency and they may have to start with this little protocol. So this little
protocol is take one to two tablespoons of apple cider vinegar with each meal. If that causes
burning too. So if HCl taking HCl with the digestive enzymes causes burning okay we've got major
stomach issues quite possibly a stomach ulcer. If taking two tablespoons, one to two tablespoons
of apple cider vinegar with each meal. Oh my gosh I can't tolerate that either. My stomach is
killing me. Typically this is a person that's taking a PPI like Prylasec or something like that. We're
trying to get them off of Prylasec. And if this is causing burning then we have to go and work on
healing the gastric lighting which is like you see you know the glycerized licorice and you know
different stages that will help just heal the stomach lighting. We have to do that for a couple weeks
two a month. But most of you you know I haven't had anybody that's been this bad for quite a while
that couldn't even tolerate apple cider vinegar. But you could just follow this chart. So if this is
you so the person who asked this question let's go back to the question. In you talk about testing
with apple cider vinegar a few years ago I was taking apple cider vinegar and developed terrible
paid and murdered. I had to go on Prylasec to get better. So a Prylasec will really decrease your
symptoms but that you do not want to go on Prylasec. Less your life depended upon it. We got it
healed up the stomach using things like slippery album and there's different herbs and marshmallow
and different things like that that will help heal the stomach. So if you take HCL and you get
murdered. If you take apple cider vinegar and you get murdered it's a sign that you have really damaged
ucocellity of the stomach and possibly the duodenum and possibly the lower part of the esophagus
and high possibility of an ulcer. So we have to heal that first. So and you might that might have
to go on an antibiotic for a period of time to kill the age pyloric also to knock it down and then treat
that. So I would start with that clear digested and most people can tolerate so I wouldn't be afraid of
taking HCL. It's going to do worst case scenario is cause birding for a little bit. You're only taking
it with your meal and it's only going to cause birding for a few minutes if the worst case scenario so
I have been doing blood glucose monitoring first. I think it's already my numbers have been 108
to 117. Okay, that's not good. So I don't need to scare you but that's pre-diabetic. That's
syndrome X. That's not where we want to be. So and people will go and you might be thinking this
how in the world I eat like this perfect diet. I don't eat any sugar. How in the world can I be
pre-diabetic because it's it's not just your diet that can damage the cell membranes. So the
reason why a person has elevated glucose the reason why a person has type two diabetes is because the
glucose can't get into the cell because the membranes of the cell have are damaged and the receptors the
insulin receptors of the cell membranes are damaged. So what could cause that? Well, you know, a
poor diet could cause that. Eating weight, a poor diet, let's break it down to pieces. A poor
diet eat way too much sugar over a period of time could cause that because it's just it overstabulates
the receptors. The insulin receptors are the cell membranes and other receptors just don't work very
well. But that's not always the case. Some people have eaten a wonderful diet and they
end up developing type two diabetes. Well, how is that? It can be because of other exposures to chemicals
in things that affect and damage that receptor that that that that is a due to an excess sugar
consumption. So that can damage the the receptors on the cell membrane. And then and then lastly that
we're talking about type two diabetes versus type one diabetes. That's totally different. It's completely
different disease. So this this is not type one diabetes. This is a diabetes, but this is prediabetic
because you really are fasting blog glucose should be under 100. Now we want to get it down into
the 70s. That's what we want to get it down to. So we got to look at you know and everybody's
an individual here. So if a person is like, I only weigh a hundred and six pounds as it is,
was boss to stop eating any carbohydrates? No, no. So there's certain things that Trump getting
our blog glucose down into the 70s. And what is that we don't want to put ourselves into the
state of kexia. So we have to be cognizant of that before we make that next decision. So maybe we
should have a chat. The ion pro wave folder has four foot bath programs. The shortest foot bath programs
is I don't know some to solar 54 to 90 minutes. If I want to do a shorter program on occasion,
can I use the one of the shorter ones that are already built in the computer? Yes, absolutely. So
you could, I mean, it has an ion pro wave folder that has about 40 different ion pro wave programs
and you could certainly pick a different one too. I have a UTI and tried to treat it with the
right and the manos, but it wasn't working. So I am now on nitro a feridol. Should I take a
probiotic while I'm taking an antibiotic bottom rule the bottom line rule just across the board
if you have to take an antibiotic, you should take a probiotic with it. You can take it with it
and mid between doses also. So let's say if you're taking the antibiotic twice a day,
once in the morning, let's say you take it at night o'clock and once in the evening, let's say you
take it at six o'clock, you could take a probiotic at night o'clock, take a probiotic at one o'clock
and take another probiotic with your dose of antibiotic at six o'clock. There's been numerous studies
that have come out that said if you take a probiotic and it wasn't even specific to what type of
probiotic. So just take whatever you have. Just take a probiotic. Take a probiotic when you're taking
the antibiotic. It was a sharp decrease in gut damage and loss of microbiota if you take a probiotic
with an antibiotic. So the answer is yes. What does metastasis to the bone pain feel like?
Well, so it depends. So it depends. If I have metastasis to the spine, I might not really have
any pain whatsoever until there is a degree of bone loss that could cause a fracture. So when I
have a fracture from caused from bone loss because of metastasis to the bone that's called a pathological
fracture. So it's not a fracture because I fell down the stairs. It's a fracture because it broke
because of lack of bone density because of a lytic lesion in the case of metastasis. So a person may
not have any bone pain with metastasis to the bone. A person may have bone pain. If they do have bone
pain, it would feel like a deep ache, a deep ache. Now if it was a metastasis to the spine and now you
have pain because that that vertebral body, let's say, fractured, then that fracture causes a decrease
in height of the vertebral body. And you'll have pinching of the vertebral ferramid where the hole
between the two vertebral bodies, two opposing vertebral bodies, the hole on each side where the
spinal nerve exits from the spine, the ferramid, the hole, the body hole that that nerve exits
will be squashed. And you'll have pinching of the nerve and that will cause pain. And that can
cause pain wherever that nerve is going so that could follow that nerve. So just like if you had a
disc that ruptured and ruptured into the vertebral ferramid and pinched the nerve, you'd have paid,
you know, for your lumbar spine, you'd have paid down your leg. So it depends on where the fracture,
where the bone metastasis is. Most bone metastasis, you won't have a lot of pain unless there's
a fracture. So, you know, it's, you know, it goes in stages. So you'll have a lot, you'll just
instantly have all this loss of bone and have a fracture. You'll have a loss of bone over time.
And, you know, a bone metastasis takes time to develop. So you would probably have other signs and
symptoms that would lead you to get an x-ray or to get a pet skin because you're not feeling good,
and your energy is down and fatigue, and it just, it's wrong with me. I just don't feel well,
and I'm losing weight. And then they do a pet skin, and oh, yeah, I'm a metastasis to, you know,
your 12th thoracic and your first lumbar and your, and your 12th rib on the right. Well,
you didn't have any pain in that area, but it was other signs and symptoms that, you know, brought you in
to get tested, and that's why you ended up, you don't go in and get any of the pet skin.
That was a 12-day predisone pack. Sorry, left and off, we're all here.
On predisone, again, for sciatica and the iliac paid, is it okay to still do coffee enemas as they
say at caffeine, not good with predisone? Yeah, probably, you should probably lay off the coffee
enemas while you're doing predisone. Now, you will absorb some caffeine. I mean, people will absorb
different amounts of caffeine, doing coffee enemas. Some people don't absorb any, some people absorb
more. And however, there's that cytochrome P450 gene on your genetic test that, yeah, if you have
defects in that, you don't detoxify coffee very well. And if you don't have defects in that one gene,
you detoxify coffee quite well, caffeine, I mean, coffee. So that would partly be a factor too,
but you might want to lay off the coffee enemas for those 12 days. A different amide is not
managed either diabetes very well with sugars, often around 300. That's not that'll cover with
diabetes. Also more recently, blood pressure issues, over 270 ish, that's not good.
Blood pressure meds take, make her dizzy and have other side effects, so not taking it as often
as recommended. And really, the statistics on blood pressure medication, unfortunately, really,
they really only bring the blood pressure down to about 10 points. I thought very much. So there's
other, you know, other alternative functional things to do with with that that actually work much
better. Do you have regimens? You suggest on your site any suggestions at how to proceed
not allopathic way. Branded diet for diabetes, but not sure how to proceed. I know there's a lot
to ask, but it is, it is very serious. And this person has to get very serious about their diet.
So yeah, I don't think I have a whole lot about diabetes yet in the autoimmune course. I'm
going to be adding a bunch of stuff about it. You have a ton of stuff about heart disease
in the blog. I have a whole series called functional cardiology that talks about heart disease.
So I think there's a series of five or six or seven blogs about that going to depth about
functional cardiology and what happens with your blood vessels and what you could do to help with that.
I don't know if that would be helpful to her. Definitely if she doesn't have cancer, she should be on
an atroxide product. That would be the most helpful for her. That really wouldn't help with the
diabetes, but it would help with the blood pressure. Diabetes is a difficult thing to manage because
it's damaged cell membranes, and then cells that are reproducing cells that have damaged cell
membranes. And it's not an easy thing to fix. For blood sugars, opera, there she probably does have to
investigate insulin as an intervention, because ultimately she's going to have glycolytic plaque
in her arteries. That's probably why she's got the high blood pressure and glycolytic plaque in her
brain, and not to be scary at global doom, but this is definitely what leads to early dementia.
So both Parkinson's with its corebitities and Alzheimer's, Alzheimer's has been suggested to be diabetes type
three, because it has so much time to diabetes type two. Rife raises it down to 20 points, so that's
encouraging. I will be adding a bunch of stuff in by this fall on diabetes in the
chronic disease autoimmune course. I'm going to just continue to add to that course. So
you can look at that. This person can also make do a case review with me too.
I can help put together a protocol for as well. So okay, any other questions?
All right. Well, thanks everybody for being on.
And I will see you all next week. I'm praying for you, and I love you all, and hope you're
getting out and enjoying your summer. Bye-bye now.